hey guys it's just you and I'm here with
Rome and then again I'm so excited about
this because I've been actually eyeing
this up for months they see the mario
kart track my Hot Wheels okay this is
like bigger than any Christmas present
I've ever gotten in my entire life
well today it's not even Christmas but
if it won't ever be here earlier look
how big this is it says now you can
raise Mario Kart in real life there's a
black powder this is so cool there's a
motorized power booster Hot Wheels track
connection so you can probably actually
connect other Hot Wheels tracks whoo you
can race yeah yeah you can read them
they're gonna race it comes with I think
Mario and Luigi but I got a little
Spanish in pack Bowser also mario luigi
so duplicates and then we have an
exclusive Yoshi as well
oh no one need de batteries
Mike do we have udsd batteries let me go
check let me know I do this every guy's
okay this is awesome oh my gosh okay
I've got the batteries this is castle
is that a Bowser's Castle Oh
instructions no I've never had a Hot
Wheels this is my first time I've never
this is my first time I've ever played
with hot we need to which I'm kind of
surprised because I feel like I would
have been so into them as a kid it's
just this is legit look at this row
because we did not have this in her
childhood now have it now and that's all
it matters
Wow okay I thought it was gonna be able
to gather know what they're doing game
one yeah we have to build this oh I
don't like building but that's okay he's
so cute I always was sad the goombahs
was the bad guys because look how cute
they are are very cute I just think
they're so cute I would keep them as a
pet I have faith that we can do this
okay one Oh No do you fill ups I do I do
I have every screwdriver
I have ranch in gonna start setting up
into
okay
Justine well I think some progress oh
very nice oh my lip gloss I was
wondering where this was these haven't
standard the small and the large I can't
believe this is our first time with Hot
Wheels but what you played with Legos
right it was a huge lego fan so I feel
like that's kind of also a crappy
antonius do you remember those Oh got
you sit through that heading down the
steps and it would just be so sad as a
car I did have one of the cars yeah you
broke
yeah it just like shattered I am
struggling to comprehend how this goes
together and then I got a guinea pig
okay hop me wait this the batteries in
there this is facing this way we're
gonna put this oh my god that got really
heavy with all those batteries in there
jump up here and then fell come on boom
very we are probably gonna need to like
zoom out on this frame when it's gonna
be huge
okay so this is their long one this
should not be this complex I'm not sure
why
oh wait I'm struggling I need something
I did something I did something backside
it goes up and around yeah okay so this
goes up and around looks right no this
has to go somewhere as well that's like
where they launch from I look at means
these are launch buttons oh this is so
cool my mom will be home credible this
is sliding it on slide and snap this is
a genuine smile
you didn't look how cool this is okay so
all rights really neat so this it kind
of curves to the side you see okay yeah
here I'll put this in boom don't wanna
miss hoping oh wait oh there's other
pieces over here loo looks yours here
here
miles are in the computer like I can
build a robot
I think build a computer and Here I am
freaking trying to figure out Hot Wheels
you can quote a website what is happy to
my small mind but this is something that
I've never used before we've never
experienced Hot Wheels so we don't have
I've never been into toys I've never had
these kind of things I don't know how
this works
what are you using those connectors that
looks crap yeah this is good okay this
is this is so exciting yeah this goes in
here
Justine how'd I miss that entire step no
it's okay
yeah it's well it's weird because kids
toys are don't you know what we don't
need this one actually because this
connects secare Justine I'm gonna say
I'm very impressed with you I'm you know
I mean you know we're gonna do a nice
jail you you understand FB I don't know
if it's gonna work yet whoa let's slip
this around this is so freaking cool
this is huge does this fit yeah in the
frame maybe see us okay let's turn this
guy on ready yeah yeah what does this do
this is me what is it no I think I knock
you off there I try to knock you off
that make sense so this goes down for
every lap so we can determine are you
ready
[Applause]
literally our flags now just read in
blue oh my god okay should we do it
again check like a couple of beginner
yes okay all right three two one
Oh
[Applause]
oh all right okay okay all right so I'm
you're really stressed out
oh my god look II know it's a friend you
know women face is the coolest thing
ever
I feel like come here see it's okay part
of my childhood we just we just relived
a childhood experience we never had this
was so fun I feel like one day when it's
like a slow video day we get as many Hot
Wheels tracks as we can and just oh
nothing I'm sure someone has already
done this before so it's probably not an
original idea but because this is
completely new to me a whole room if we
can do that I'm probably gonna end up by
all of my youtube recommendations are
now gonna be Hot Wheels videos well guys
thank you for watching thumbs up for Hot
Wheels hit back
yeah and bail for hot wait who like and
you subscribe and ring the bell
make sure you go check out rose channel
we have been making so many videos
lately check it out and uh I will see
you guys our next video
[Music]